hello welcome back to new rockstars
debrief I'm Erik Voss joining me today
are Sam basher Maude Garrett that's me
and we have a special guest joining us
on the panel today
Erin couch he covers Marvel and many
other things for The Hollywood Reporter
welcome Erin hey thanks for having me
guys alright we got it this is a fun new
lineup we have here new chemistry new
combinations
what kind of sparks will fly I think can
happen in that revolvers chambers oh boy
not a good analogy okay today guys let's
get to the real topic
Captain Marvel it opens this weekend we
also got some juicy footage that was
shown at a Disney shareholder meeting
and get some news about the future of
Deadpool inside the MCU and here is your
friendly reminder that this episode is
also available as a podcast in case you
want to paint your own picture of what
we look like in your heads it's always
more thrilling that way and you can find
it on the Himalaya app Apple podcast etc
wherever your podcasts and you can
really help us out by subscribing to
this podcast through Himalaya because
they're actually about to cross a
thousand subs over there after five
weeks very exciting
we might get a pizza party I believe in
wishful thinking all right let's get
started
in today's episode as I said Captain
Marvel the biggest story this week this
movie is directed by Anna boda and Ryan
fleck it's starring brie Larson and a
young samuel l.jackson thanks the use of
Disney's uncanny CGI technology official
effects oh boy
did it work yeah I thought I was
watching I thought it was in the early
90s watching a movie but there's a lot
to talk about here alright there's lots
of different ways you can look at this
movie so I thought maybe we'd break it
up a bit
ask a few leading questions to keep us
focused a bit first of all this is a
question we're seeing a lot online gain
excited I'm going binary as we speak
this is a question a lot of people are
asking can you skip this movie and just
go straight to endgame now this is a
question that we have seen a lot and
then see you before with movies like
ant-man with Doctor Strange some of
these solo chapters that aren't
necessarily have they don't have
Avengers or Captain America
in the title the movie or Iron Man so
this is a fair question to ask
let's also acknowledge that it's a
question that's being asked in different
context you know it was asking the
question in the context of Black Panther
and now it's been asked by different
people for Captain Marvel so if that's
the reason you're asking it if you're
one of those people who considers
themself fueled by an ism or even if you
don't if you haven't checked your
privilege yet just but it's not a
conversation we're having here go to
other places talk about that we just
want to get into like the reasons why
this movie might not be mandatory or
might be more mandatory for MCU Watchers
and is this connected as much as we want
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe so what
do we think is this a movie that you
need to fully understand and appreciate
endgame
have I seen this movie I mean kicking it
off I I say yes 100% Carol Danvers and
Captain Marvel are more recently for
Marvel comics have become more and more
she's become more and more important
she's even like led the Avengers or The
Ultimates or name a different team
that's not the Avengers and it's I've
always loved like the cosmic site of
what she brings to the table because
Marvel you always think it's the thing
that's been thrown around a lot it's a
it's the smaller scale it's the more
grounded characters but it's like well
it's sometimes fun to throw in like a
Superman level character every once in a
while and it's nice that like that
character exists I don't know how you
really there's any threat against her
going forward but we'll have to see that
in future movies I'm excited to see how
we explore that and what this adds to
the MCU in terms of who where she comes
from her valence her side characters and
what that could mean for future other
heroes they're also very popular Marvel
comics right now that would be amazing
on the big screen it makes me excited
and I can't wait to see her an end game
and moving forward you know I mean I
want to throw this over to you guys I
feel like just my point of view this is
so much more connected surprisingly to
the MCU than I ever would expect
certainly more than like spider-man
homecoming even with Tony Stark in it
like the I mean we're gonna get into
some spoilers in this conversation but
the fact that they tie in an infinity
stone into this story they tie in the
origin of Nick Fury and the whole
Avengers initiative I things I was not
expected and we're real pleasant
surprises that made this feel like more
of a Marvel fanfare than I expected
they're my thing is if you want to know
a full picture you know
want to see the full scale of everything
why would you want to miss a part of it
yeah and sometimes you know you do have
to look forward look back to see what's
up ahead and I think that's what this
movie does a really good job of you're
right I do believe this is a great Nick
Fury origin story do you
is it super integral to know how she got
the powers no because we start off with
Carol Danvers already powered up and
ready to go so in terms of sort of like
finding out her origin and history not
necessarily I just think it's like more
fulfilling knowing where we're going
with endgame to have that backstory of
integral characters like where the
Avengers formed and all that kind of
stuff yeah
Aaron how do you think this compares to
like some of the other newcomer to the
MCU stories like Doctor Strange or Black
Panther recently did this successfully
make Carol Danvers Captain Marvel feel
like an essential member of this team
you know I think that there really
hasn't been a disappointing Marvel movie
in a really long time I mean I would say
for me Avengers age of Ultron that was
four years ago ever since then I haven't
been walked away disappointed some have
been greater than others oh are you an
Ultron fan it's good to be positive
Quicksilver Kovach no not Aaron you
bring up a good point everything kind of
feels like essential and like Marvel has
so much control over these movies and
making them whether or not you like the
fact that they might feel similar to
each other they all are crowd pleasers
very much so and you know I think that
there are highs and there are no lows
from either maybe bigger highs like
Black Panther and infinity war and stuff
like that so know that this one maybe
wasn't as high as Black Panther or
infinity war for me but man it was a
great movie and gave you a lot of stuff
I wasn't expecting which we'll probably
talk about but yeah you know even even
things like the scrolls I thought uh
whatever you know and then you see him
these guys are awesome it was so fun and
I wasn't expecting that so in an Origin
movie for Carol and learning her side of
the cosmic like Marvel Universe learning
more about the scrolls it was like oh
man
being shapeshifters that super dope and
when as soon as you give it to anybody
else you're like oh that's terrifying
like actually like there's super hate
this like and I love the humor you got
out of that and like the genuine threat
you're like cool so it's like they
change on the genetic level which I have
no idea what that means but that just
means oh it's scary
Bad News Bears we bears out of this how
does the creature not have unique DNA I
have some questions about the science of
that
Vsauce get on that right now I think the
I get some of them may be less
enthusiastic responses some people may
have I've heard some people describe the
tone of this movie and the I guess
inconsistent tone some are saying as
feeling like Marvel phase 1 movie like
maybe the first or the first Captain
America and that like you know maybe
this character not necessarily the
acting but like the overall direction of
the movie and the tone the humor the
fact that some scenes feel like they're
out of a different movie than the scene
that came before it feeling like it's a
little scattered so some people are
reacting that way like did I need this
story to be part of it or can we just
see Carol Danvers jump into the fun of
Avengers in game and see her already
powered up and already mixed in with the
rest of the team I'd say just the one
criticism that like walking away from
the movie it was I didn't know anybody's
name into like 15 minutes into the movie
yeah I was like I knew because what we
do here I didn't know Jude Law's
character name in the beginning of the
movie by a third act I was like gone
rogue I'm like oh don't remember but
like as soon as I said like yeah I
remember
and also vers I'm like did they you had
to have said it but it just didn't feel
like the movie just kind of like oh the
trains already going and we're seeing it
as it goes by we didn't see where it
started and I'm like and you're kind of
meant to be thrown in there because
that's where she's at right or that's an
angle you could look at this way I would
think the blood color and his Sheikh
Ayman isn't she human what is going on
you see it a little bit more than what
you're giving like just like a something
like like guardians the galaxy starts
with like Peter being abducted you're
like okay and then we can jump into mid
adventure because we know like Oh
Howard this kids grew up this way and
like you didn't need that intro but
something that was just like her name is
verse and that's at least as much as I
know a different plan a different game
didn't I say it but like I was super
like I was
like I actually don't know what's
happening in this first act until like
when she gets to earth I'm like and now
I get it and I'm on board all the way to
the end there's like the emit pics I
just say the one thing I was like I wish
like the beginning was like a cohesive
like kickstart to who she is it was
giving you a lot of exposition at once
it was setting up the her relationship
with Jude Law who this entity was and
why it changed shape and what it
represented and she has this chip in her
neck when why that's important you just
like wait yeah I'm on board the crowd
but like a she's great we were
definitely inundated with information I
wonder I mean Nicole Perlman did a pass
on this script I think she wrote the
first draft of it and she wrote the
Guardians the first Guardian script I'm
not sure about a second before James
Gunn took it over and it felt like to me
that scribes of Marvel movies are now
expecting Marvel fans to be at a certain
level of like just going with it you
know they're on a different planet but I
do agree with you guys it felt like the
first act of this movie was very
ambitious I did love the ensemble though
there that squadron which I thought was
probably the best version of a Green
Lantern movie I've ever seen
I really liked that and then of course
it was over I do want their toys I
really want their toys especially I like
all like the light-up sores and the
gauntlets and that magnet the vacuum
thing whatever Jude Law was playing
around with big fan of that
yeah well another question Aaron I want
to ask you about this the like this
whole idea of brie Larson signing on for
a multi-picture deal to play this
character there were some reports out
there that she had signed up to seven
movies in the Marvel Universe we don't
know if that's true but she's obviously
going to be an in-game and Marvel
intends on her being a big front man or
woman and that's in this next lineup in
phase four how do you think she'll fit
in with the Avengers do you see brie
Larson as having the same kind of
chemistry with Tony Stark and Hulk and
Thor that like spider-man was able to
have yeah I mean I think that's the big
question mark I know um last week you
guys were talking about this they what's
next in right yeah you know who knows
Evans is probably gone maybe Downey
isn't doing as much or he's gone so I
think that I would imagine
that they have to be thinking chadwick
boseman and brie Larson are going to be
the faces of the Marvel Universe going
forward right so yeah so maybe I don't
know what that means in terms of is she
the leader because he's also you know
he's the king so I don't know if he's
gonna be second banana or second fiddle
but I all those questions sound fun to
me to explore you know yeah
but I imagine that you know I we what we
all do is essentially write fanfiction
so I'm like oh she's gonna go out and
then when they get the you know the
Fantastic Four and the MCU she'll
discover them out in space as explorers
or something so I imagine they'll be a
bunch of cosmic stuff that'll be fine I
think she would have made a better see
read as soon as you said that I was like
trying to picture Captain Marvel talking
to see reading I'm like she yeah I do
like her I do like her as as Captain
Marvel I like I do like her I where she
can be serious when she wants to achieve
me playful as well I like a lot more
faith in her moments it's when she
really had to knuckle down and go super
saiyan like she just wasn't really
bringing that hero moment I felt like
she just didn't have enough sort of like
what do you call a gust oh like you see
man Ben Mendelsohn who just went light
to dark and dark to light like so
effortlessly and we're in that Benny and
how much fun she brought to that take
home and even Georgie's all kind of you
know really just running out of F's and
just going hard for it it's like she
just couldn't shed off some sort of like
I don't know I don't know if it's ego
but just like she just couldn't kind of
ham it up and have fun mmm yeah I see
what you're saying mod to meet you the
performance that brie brought to it
reminded me a lot of Sebastian Stan and
Captain America Winter Soldier it's a
similar kind of role right brainwashed
super soldier is still figuring out what
his past is and he's there a lot more
fun in Civil War where he understood who
the character was he was on the other
side of that brainwash he is now dealing
with the betrayal the PTSD and I think
I'm looking forward to what brie Larson
brings to future role
because it's a really difficult role to
play someone who's in the midst of being
brainwashed and trying to remember their
their erased and really quickly I know I
really quick just want to say really
really quick I as a comparison to
somebody I think that grew into their
role and the role grew around them chris
hemsworth or was basically from one to
vengers one two and his movies I'm like
I don't know who you are and it kind of
doesn't matter because you're basically
reading some fanfiction but of
Shakespeare and it doesn't mean anything
to me but by Ragnar and endgame I mean
hey
he's a good-looking chap I'm a big fan
but like by Ragnarok and an end game I
was like oh I now know that you've been
on the journey and I actually care about
it by this point and that he became
fun-loving swashbuckling pirate I'll
make a lot of sense and be really really
good if this was not the first movie
that she'd filmed guys she filmed this
movie after endgame I know at the same
time as infinity war and then after I
was like she's just got a training
wheels she's just and know guys I asked
her I said is it true that you filmed
this movie after endgame and she's like
yes and it really helped because I was
able to really learn about my character
and get more and I was like stopped
well here's the thing it's you brought
up a good point we do need to see her on
screen with two chala with these
characters that she's actually going to
be in phase four with and hopefully
hopefully an end game we'll be able to
see some of the actual chemistry that
she'll need to have in order to carry
the legacy of the MC forward in the
future you keep saying that Captain
America's going but picture this Captain
America Captain Marvel you cannot have a
ship with that your captain I've used
that before but it's so good because I'm
shipping those two together you know
what's fun is they don't say Captain
Marvel at any point during the runtime
they know that there was another nitpick
there's at the sink and he says Marvel
like the Marvel but talking about a dead
person and then by the end the Captain
Marvel logo comes up I was like I like I
mean I can understand writing wise where
you get to that point that she calls
herself that or she in honor of but I'm
like I didn't I didn't get to that but
they're both they both have served time
we pick the country they have that to
bond over
they're like military service either
frozen or in another you know hemisphere
like in the galaxy in another universe
yeah I just think I got a lot of
catching up to do yeah and I think that
the two boring characters could actually
maybe this is the spot they needed this
is out of water right like they're
having fun a little bit which is his job
is to be serious and to run it to be a
leader and it says schematics kind of
like mindset that he's got good imagine
those two yeah you know I think pretty I
think overall this whole movie is very
fun I don't think this movie itself I
don't think Marvel as a studio and it's
I don't think the filmmakers forgot to
have fun because I found myself laughing
and enjoying this whole movie it
honestly felt like I was onboard one of
those like theme park rides like Star
Tours or guardians the galaxy mission
breakout a Disneyland and you're just
like enjoying the ride and you're
laughing you're cheering all the
peripheral elements are awesome you
don't necessarily have that like central
protagonist who's emotional arc you're
attached to but they do it such a good
job with the production that you don't
really care yeah and I mean I feel that
way about a lot of Marvel movies I'm not
just throwing that on Captain MoMA
honestly like probably 60% of Marvel
movies I feel that way about what
happened with this movie well this maybe
in particular is that it was supposed to
be a standalone origin story but it
ended up being completely interwoven
with Nick Fury's origin story so I'm
wondering if it was all about Bri and
then like there was a lot less of fury
and I don't know whether they were just
like oh this isn't strong enough which
maybe she can't carry this for her own
movie or is this secretly supposed to be
Captain Marvel's movie but there's been
there's just a lot of Nick Nick Fury
yeah interweaving with it as well which
I'm kind of grateful for like I really
enjoyed that aspect and I enjoyed
meeting and seeing his character I think
they worked really well together oh yeah
I have a good dynamic which I'm
appreciative of I just wanna know what
came first well I'm curious to see I
feel like they're setting up Captain
Marvel 4 to have a future series of
movies at least one sequel where do we
think this sequel
there be one we'll go are we seeing
something that will take place before
the current era and we'll see the next
chapter with ronan or going back to the
Kree homeworld of hala or do we see
maybe the next Captain Marvel movie
might introduce Monica Rambeau into the
end of the storyline what do you guys
think are we gonna get a weird back like
door origin for why Ronan became like a
crazy he's like we gotta go after I'm
like why live in a time buddy like I
mean you're about to go like try to
commit genocide like for a whole planet
like it's like and he's like edging
towards it from like this three lines he
had in the movie I'm not complaining but
it was just like well he didn't so are
we good five points to Gryffindor but I
maybe we might get that honestly have
her team-up
I would like her and fury again but her
and Ben Mendelsohn they playing off each
other really well he's so good I can't
believe he acted like me he's great
actor but I can't believe he acted
through all of this and you knew it was
like he didn't know is him but you knew
who Talos was which whenever I it was
one of those words that was you know you
there's some words you read and you
never say out loud and you're like like
uh Bruce Cate or something like that
there's like one word I'm like I always
see it I've never said out loud and so
when I hear for the first time like the
Pokemon Aipom I said that wrong forever
you just tell me the story about that
it's I don't believe there is any right
or wrong way to say a made-up thing a
p.m. there you go all words are made up
but no I honestly having them team-up
scrolls and also they they set up the
idea that there are small colonies of
Scrolls out there Secret Invasion would
be such a cool story I know we did a
shape surf there story but it was such a
small aspect of this this secret story
and I would really like do you think
this story like nipped the idea of
secret invasion in the butt or is it I
wish that Irish what is Jude Law is
character
yawn rod I wish that he was actually
keeping everyone in his team in the dark
I wish that they were so sort of like
lion soldiers they just looked at their
commander for the decisions and they all
find out that they're fighting for the
wrong team as well I kind of wished that
would happen so we have a little bit
more allies and we have more use of
these team because it they seemed really
really cool and all the sudden it was
like oh cool you seem really fun then
and now you're all jerks and I've gotta
kill you so long God you know what a
waste
I wish Minerva had made it Jim and Chan
I'm big fan except for her joke was
actually pretty good I just wish she had
made it past that but it was like oh is
this why we'd ever hung out it was like
no I just didn't like you gotta kill you
now in a really awful way philanthropist
people burn up suffocating on Bad News
Bears again times 2 the sequel just
saying every time you say it it's weed
it's so Aaron and your fanfiction for
the future of Captain Marvel which
sequel idea whether it's Secret Invasion
or tying in with the guardians of the
galaxy or whatever else do you think
gets you most excited potentially for
cap tomorrow yeah I think that a Secret
Invasion is something that I really
really want to see and because I think
you take a lot of guts if they actually
made somebody that we care about a
scroll I mean I would make me up yeah
but man that'd be really cool or someone
we care you know maybe okay yeah babies
he had kids yeah scroll maybe three kids
girl kids scroll Legos it stepped on a
farm yeah yeah that scroll logs that
they were chopping there it's all
connected well we have a lot of thoughts
we'll be making more and more videos
about Captain Marvel we're gonna do a
full Easter egg breakdown we're gonna
talk about that infinity stone that
found its way in the movie we're gonna
talk about who might win in the duel
with a between a floor Ken and a mad
Titan because it suits pretty evenly
matched if you ask me but let us know
your thoughts about Captain Marvel in
the comments below and yeah keep it
civil as I mentioned before we're just
nerds talking about nerd stuff here and
we ain't getting political both oh
they'll be all
but yeah moving on to this week's trivia
question may I kindly you guys are
familiar this is a one of my favorite
segments of the show we're gonna be
reading out a trivia question you all
need to write your best answer same here
because I am not familiar with what this
answer will be and the winner gets to do
the outro and the loser needs to pick
time to get the shame box exactly we
wrote down some suggestions let's see
how we do all right here we go quick
trivia question what town does Nick Fury
reveal he was born in - Captain Marvel
alright all of our answers are here in
the buckets will reveal the answer at
the end of the episode and it's were you
listening that closely during Captain
Marvel answer the comments below
we won't know whether or not you looked
it up okay but first we want to get to
someone we want to give a special shout
out to Robin Hood Robin Hood is an
investing app that lets you buy and sell
stocks ETFs options and Kryptos all
commissioned free while other brokerages
charge up to $10 for every trade Robin
Hood doesn't charge any Commission fees
so you can trade stocks and keep all of
your profits plus there is no account
minimum deposit needed to get started
you can just start investing at any
level the simple intuitive design of
Robin Hood makes investing easy for
newcomers and experts alike view easy to
understand charts and market data and
place a trade in just four taps of your
smartphone you can also view stock
collections such as 100 most popular
with Robin Hood you can learn how to
invest in the market as you build your
portfolio discover new stocks track your
favorite companies and get custom
notifications for price movements so you
never miss the right moment to invest
Robin Hood is giving listeners of new
rockstars a free stock like Apple Ford
or sprint to help you build your
portfolio just sign up at rockstars dot
Robin Hood com is exciting it seems like
I'm old enough to care a lot about that
to lay people like us get all the
players we can and steal from the rich
and give to the pole yeah that's what
hopefully we need more Robin Hood's in
this world
Sam what have you heard this week
somewhere updates well guess what gang
according to we got this covered and
their sources did pull yes Deadpool will
definitely be appearing in the MCU films
following the Disney Fox deal hooting it
almost definitely wouldn't include
endgame or spider-man far from home
because these movies have already been
shot but even so this seems pretty
tricky for one thing I mean if the
Avengers ever showed Deadpool a picture
of Thanos he probably be really confused
that's us buddies his power from the
future that's clearly you never seemed
in the same place do you
I mean I shook his hand the actor who
played in Thanos no no I would my hand
would be broken but seriously which
movie would you want to appear in first
oh like whose movie whose future movie
do you want Deadpool to pop up I want to
see when a spider-man movie right like
that seems like the to the character of
Deadpool was made as kind of like an
edgier darker version of spider-man
sorry the guy you need finesse and that
power gauntlet with magneto sometimes
magneto can grab Thor's hammer too it's
kind depends on who's right and what
like it just depends on who wants to
change the rules for that in the comics
but I mean like comedic Lee speaking the
way Chris Hemsworth is taking taken Thor
forward I would love to see a sequel to
Ragnarok with Hemsworth with Ruffalo as
Hulk and then adding deadpool to that
mix and make a perfect trio o hangover I
like the power levels of that because
it's like Thor and Hulk can take a
beating but that who can put it in the
wrong way where it's like fighting
against it's like it's not like fighting
a boulder it's like the guns gonna last
cuz it's gonna come back together so
it's like you'll get some licks in but
he's not gonna be doing super hot like
that sounds actually that's beyond
wavering and
he's got the yucks I would I also like
the idea of a Spider Man Deadpool
team-up because in the comics right now
there's a Spider Man Deadpool comic and
the pitch is great it's just like it's
dead pulls a huge fan of spider-man and
spider-man wants nothing he's a murderer
he doesn't want anything to do with them
and it that released that was the
beginning of the run now it's changed
he's been going on for 50 issues this is
a bound to change every once in a while
but I I love that idea but also Deadpool
being a part of the
and trying to be like a good person was
always a fun start like recently there
was an uncanny Avengers run where he
funded the Avengers because he like he
finally sold out and he sold his own
merch and he made billions and so like
nothing I've been just had no funding so
like Deadpool had to be a part of the
team and he had to like and he was like
no killing but he still went in with not
like swords and guns and everything is
great yeah big van I literally didn't
want him in them Cu it but you've
convinced me these all sound great I
thought oh there's no way you can't work
okay I'm sold yeah yeah that's that's it
I mean they'd ride Disney rerelease
Deadpool to the pg-13 cut the holiday
release right and it did make a ton of
money but I think it's mostly just
because people had already seen this
story like either through the super
duper cut when they release it on
blu-ray or in the theatrical cut when
they release it in May I need you to
water down my hard liquor yeah it just
depends how they water it down they'll
have to tone down some of the violence
some of the sexual humor but they're
able to get away with a lot of bad
language and well yeah is a big word in
the movie was saying something different
down under different cultures you know
but we also got some interesting casting
news regarding Suicide Squad do we who
will smith was out we've talked about
that but apparently Adriel eat wrist
elbow is in as the same character that's
what's floating around right now on the
Internet along with eaters elbow we're
also hearing that Margot Robbie will
reprise her role as Harley Quinn and
that we could see some new characters to
buckle up click click here we go we
could be seeing everyone's favorite
characters ratcatcher king shark big fan
poke it out man and peacemaker who could
be played by dave bautista that's
actually interesting one
I love King shark it big shark big
muscles he's got a hands he grew he
growls and grumbles big fan if you guys
watch the flash right now he is the best
part of that I love it and peace maker I
learned more about right now
fun fact he is the basis of the comedian
from Watchmen so that's super cool
by it loosely because after a while they
kind of had a train change a peacemaker
a little bit and he kills to make peace
super confusing and also he starts to
kind of go crazy because he can hear
like sometimes he can hear the voices of
the people he's killed in like all the
time it's it sounds like hell but hey if
you want some crazy people on that team
go for it also I'm guessing polka dot
man rat catcher and peacemaker might get
the Polka Dot Mendez I know in Marvel
Comics there's the spot and he's pretty
cool they look similar but he can like
make dimensional holes and reach around
and portal to I mean yeah I don't think
polka but thought man does that though I
pitched a cool character I don't know
what polka-dots gun here there's nothing
stopping him from just like revising
with their characters powers are this
guy is an otter he makes the characters
his own and just creates new I didn't
maybe yes maybe no dude you're celibate
man that's great I like the Will Smith
in that role he was my favorite part of
that movie but also he just alpha is the
man and I want to give him a hug so yeah
I'm on board yeah just a hug
whatever floats boat you know or
whatever you know whatever he's feeling
I hope you likes me yeah that's all I
got to say doesn't know Heimdall coming
back or maybe we'll know he's wanted a
bigger role and hopefully this is it for
hopefully we have some other news coming
out this week in game because footage
from that movie screened at the annual
Disney shareholder meeting this week was
leaked yes a brave soul who's obviously
never gonna be working in this country
again attended and he took to Twitter to
spill the beans major spoiler alert if
you don't want to know absolutely
anything about this movie going in zoo
just pop it forward about 35 seconds so
apparently the footage starts with
Captain Marvel Captain America Black
Widow a war machine Bruce Banner thought
rocket and nebula talking about how to
find and kill thanos so it ends with all
of them heading to space to find him
rocket drives and Captain Marvel she is
sitting right next
they're in the cockpit admin wasn't part
of this powwow though so it's probably
early in the movie before he shows up at
HQ you know really ceremony style that
we've technically already seen in the
trailer but the real question everyone
is asking is if we've got nebula there
where's Tony Stark they were grouped
together in the trailer
science scene out of this real quick how
bum do you think rocket was like ah who
lost group well all my friends are
coming it's just like uh nebula the
sister of one of your friends who
definitely tried to kill you like that's
something remotely entertaining with his
character
I like nephew I do like Matt behind like
what they did in guardians to with her
and I liked her an end game she wasn't
dude - well yeah yeah don't I think the
question is like what new tasks could
Tony be up to right now like what will
he be doing is he on his own like solo
mission like he's crawling BER event
somewhere while everyone else is they
need to work together to do something
it's like I'll take care of this
you guys just go beat up Thanos and I'll
crawl through this vent which is this
movie's depiction of time-traveling
wormholes to go back and drop them
through different rooms through the
vents screen in time of this Factory
that is how about this one confirmed
here's a pitch she makes a little pit
stop knit a valley where they made
Thor's new hammer and the other one too
Tony starts making one giant mech Iron
Man suit because I know we saw a pitch
of making a giant in laser cannon from
like the Capcom games everyone I'm on
board I love it but like what if he's
making a big suit in the last second he
like instead of like the Thor like
Rainbow Bridge entrance you see giant
mech suit and Thanos just trashed that I
mean I I want big mechs Marvel hasn't
done that yet I'd be on board I like
Pacific Rim enough even the sequel what
Big Mac Big Macs
yeah I just may I start thinking about
Big Macs that's me though what other
things happen at this shareholder me
well I'm so glad you asked because this
event which I'm gonna rename my
Christmas also showed some of the Star
Wars Episode nine footage Thank You
Disney now apparently it's not so much
sort of like a snippet from the movie
it's just flashes of things which would
probably make sense given that it
doesn't around until Christmas they
don't maybe have the full movie and a
chunk to take out from it what but what
we did here was it included again if you
don't want it spoiled ship kylo ren's
looking at Vader's helmet Billy Dee
Williams is back as Lando and there's a
shot of Ray Finn and Poe inside the
Millennium Falcon Wow I was like just
completely becoming Han Solo which I'm
absolutely not I'm so excited
Lando and then it's so interesting that
we are talking about shareholders
meetings and we're super excited about
it because I am but like in normal
business it's like Oh usually we don't
need to talk about that like it was DC
when like they started talking about
Batman V Superman and Batman being great
and that it was like from a shareholders
meeting and I was like oh we lost our
minds we got so excited over it so shout
out to shareholders meetings and the
people who snitch and probably can't
work ever again the whole problem I have
exists though is it
kylo Ren looking at Vader's helmet
that's already happened did he make a
new one there's always more time to
stare at an your grandfather's house do
you like kylo Ren are you a fan of this
news that I've delivered to you is he
just gonna be a derp you know I'm kind
of a little bit down on Star Wars lately
but I am sure I'll come back next month
when they show the trailer or something
but yeah it's just hard to be excited
after you know the last year or two
really so I really love the fact that
they've got rain Finn back together the
first part about Episode seven was their
chemistry to take them away it was like
a little bit I mean they actually
confess that when I interviewed them
they hated that they weren't acting
alongside each other and they weren't
really on set together so seeing those
two back together we yeah they're like a
description of a like a dream scene with
like kylo Ren re-experiencing the moment
where Vader got the mask sealed on his
head at the end of Revenge of the Sith
Grant and we're never really so much of
that sounds like rumor is that's gonna
be coming from like they're returning
from the beyond I'm about that with an
Infinity Gauntlet Oh
Patton Oswalt's Parks and Rec filibuster
speech oh yeah well this is exciting
hopefully we will get a trailer soon
because I I just miss the version of
myself that was excited about Star Wars
and I it's a part of it's just time too
much time has passed part of it is like
directions things have gone in movies I
did really love the last Jedi though and
died on that cross it'll care but yeah
hopefully this trailer will come out
soon and hopefully JJ will we'll get
back to what he really loved about this
with force awakens I don't know what I'm
saying but I wouldn't move on to some
other more exciting stuff so Sam's
actually gonna be talking about another
big Star Wars update in a second but
first we got some news and we want to
thank our friends over at philo we are
now going to be able to provide
breakdowns for the rest of the Walking
Dead Season 9 thanks to Philo and thank
you also for sponsoring this video now
if you want to hop on this whole Walking
Dead crazy because season 9 has been
really really good guys and so you don't
have cable like more and more people are
now you really should think about giving
Philo a try you don't need any equipment
to set up you just need a phone number
there's no contracts and it's only $20 a
month you can watch The Walking Dead on
AMC of course but they've also got
Nickelodeon content they got a any you
can watch better call Saul if you're
into that that's through AMC as well
there's like 50 other channels that you
can watch live or you can DVR for later
you can start watching within seconds
that's what's really really cool about
this app and a special special offer
just for you guys the first 50 new rock
stars fans to sign up with our link get
their first month for free so jump on
this now and thanks again to Philo I'm
looking forward to this rest of the
season of The Walking Dead Season 9 but
Sam what are some other news for this
week it's time for in other news Disney
announced that galaxy's edge the Star
Wars land they're building in their
Disney theme parks will open on May 31st
right around the corner at Disneyland in
August 29th at Disney World
along with dropping a sweet little video
promoting the attraction I want to go
opening day I don't know if I can take
off work but I really want to go next
reshoots for New Mutants are no longer
planned and that project may move from
the big screen over to Disney Plus the
news is actually broken by our game
Aaron couch I believe yeah yeah well
basically from what we understand they
there are there they need reshoots they
haven't happened so they're not planned
they could happen still and they
probably will happen eventually and you
know age to use that's a great guys you
know his voice is dropped this thing is
I don't I don't think this thing will
it's unlikely to come out be at Ramin as
Disney what going to want to release
this in August I think that Dark Phoenix
will be the last movie we see
theatrically from Fox as an excellent
movie and then you know this has been
delays attack sisters interesting the
first episode of the show that we did
was breaking down that trailer of New
Mutants like a year and a half ago by
the books horror movie but you're like
but mutants I'm like cool I'm poor with
that how could it how could you make it
like so complicated but hey who knows
speaking of scary superhero movies
bright Byrne released another trailer
that's the James Gunn produce movie that
basically asks what if Superman was a
demon or just a little baby demon oh wow
this looks awesome it like looks like
well it's looper like it the Rainmaker
care to look evil kid with powers this
trailer is freaking terrified oh man but
if he flew yeah there's something about
the image is just like a little kid
floating just like his legs dangling
this kids all over the place that's a no
from me very much tickets
it's Orwellian right don't they have the
kids be the thoughtcrime police or am i
thinking of that I know 80-84 Christian
Bale maybe I know what you're talking
about go and I don't remember I don't
try to get kids are pure and they can
like read emotions kids are not empaths
they have like four emotions speaking of
kids as in my childhood and my childhood
ending arrow is set to end after the
upcoming abridge season of ten episodes
thank you so much ten points for me in
the runway
but finally jared leto is shared a set
fro from the morbius movie that he's
starring in and it's based on a
lesser-known spiderman frenemy but as
far as we know will not connect to any
other spider-man movie shout to Matt
Smith who has been reportedly in that
movie oh great this is like perfect
casting for Jared Leto I'm so glad he's
moving away from playing Joker to
playing a character I think it's better
fit for you yeah is this his revenge
piece because we all know that you know
Will Smith his revenge over the fluffs
Suicide Squad was to become a blue Genie
so that's all that weird stuff that
Jared Leto did to his cast members on
Suicide Squad I brought them like dead
oh yeah what's the Viola Davis is the
one like I am not having any of that cut
that out
yeah but yeah but I think I'm ready for
my second favorite segment of this show
and address a question to a particular
host that you would like to answer it
are you guys ready yeah Eric you're up
first okay
from at Davy backward AB backward Deb
says what friendship Joe and Marvel / DC
are you excited or hope to see in the
big screen Minds Wiccan slash Hulk Ling
in Young Avengers pull so what
friendship Joe and Marvel DC do you want
to see like that currently exist or do
in comics okay hmm
cable and Deadpool was my favorite when
I got that movie thank you we're like oh
I want to see a
I would say Nightwing and Alfred move
was a blink question I was a flash of
Green Lantern or Black Canary and Green
Arrow sloth the smooth said what
superhero slash villain would Charlie
day hero oh man go with a weird one um I
go oh no I go with go with the cam
lightning around lightning has been Tim
Drake Robin
our marvel Wolverine there you go me ask
for second said if you aren't a Valyrian
steel sort of your own what would you
name it like the model no Mordor yes yes
one does not simply give over Mordor or
Pepe Silvia that's definitely not it
good lord but out of that question Pepe
Silvia that's not good what a severe
what is this word you're saying it's
from Charlie Day Oh No just because you
screwed up your answer for that doesn't
mean he can start whipping on it on mine
Aaron here's one you ready at cheddar
blowout says who in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has the strongest friendship
the strongest friendship yes hmm
oh it's bucking copy of course yeah yeah
but cavity bucking cap
says Sherlock Holmes and Watson versus
ash ketchum and Brock who's your
favorite friendship girls Oh first oh
yeah it surely comes in Watson it if
we're talking about me the Martin
Freeman rock just couldn't oh good
Brooke just couldn't get things up his
mind or get his eyelids open because
he's always doing this do you know what
that is Joe rule that bothered me a lot
as a teenager I'd be watching Pokemon
and then I'd be watching rules the video
clip and I was like there's something
going on here that's the only thing that
ja rule has ever done his life that
bothered welcome back to that another
one for you at Royal flash craft is if
one of the Avengers had the power of
friendship wow I'm seeing a theme who
would it be and who would use it best
this is a really sweet all these
friendship question you should ask your
friendship questions I'm friends with my
sword yeah lame power can we just say
that thanks oh you're not no one else is
capable of making friends so what bad
talking the Care Bears over here I'm
really not having it if that us had
friends do you think he'd snapping all
it no no excuse what kind of excuse oh
sure he killed his daughter but scuse
I'd go with Bruce Banner because he
hasn't a friend so he'd appreciate it
more you know really understand Tim and
they met dear he was chief choose one DC
character and one Marvel character to be
best friends
oh I go with green arrow and Hawkeye cuz
man they get ragged on a lot I'm sure
they can really support each other hey I
can do the same one well I can do the
Salmon Ladder
well you couldn't watch me murder people
with Tokyo that's why I summed up the
show arrow and the trail they in did
they meet at you H a the underrated
heroes and I'm an anonymous probably
they run it awesome hey wrapping it up
I've got another one from actually
there's a bunch more but you guys are
taking too long I asked for seconds asks
me a another question if you could earn
a Fleur can would you and if so what
would you name it um
percent I much preferred the what do you
mean why are we pushing that why what if
it like a mailman and you didn't know
anything about it is it it's dead yeah I
don't if like it and I would name it me
so every time I would communicate it
would be speaking its language putting
him down now cool that's why I don't
have cats Eric okay ninety-seven can I
be your friend sure that was the
quickest testing you've had so far
alright GGG two four eight four one four
three Oh would you rather be friends
with Batman I'll see them in I'm
Superman of course task force I'll do a
lot more
yes place is way more evil Sam at dot
Steelers fan says what does it feel that
oh this is gonna hurt isn't it what does
it mean to have a friend the meanings is
good what does it mean lightning round
it's good do people who need more
mushrooms on their chicken sandwich
anyone who gets that one probably too
many people comment down below and all
of us at Ray underscore hey Mel for all
of you what is your all-time at favorite
memory together since I met you today
good one we're having right yeah it's
just this one yeah this one before when
you guys all chastise me because I was
super late to the show on my Instagram
story at all can you make it one of
those little segments on your page that
you can always click on forever and ever
because then you can will never forget
what I did never for that well thank you
for will never forget your wonderful
questions and you are our friends but
now comes the time for our fifteen
second child where each of us has 15
seconds to shout out plug or ramble
about anything they want Sam would you
like to begin do you think quick one I
saw waitress on Broadway amazing Sarah
Bareilles you're so talented writing
music it's amazing also a do patrol in
the DC Universe app you guys tweet me
should I get that app and I've said it
like at least 20 times now yes get it
it's an amazing show if you like weird
and you're like but is it like really
weird it's like it's very weird and if
you can keep up with it do it
Brendan Fraser Matt Bomer Timothy Dalton
the cast is insane and these and it's
the first time whenever like you know in
a movie they're like but is being this
hero kind of
not fun and you're like no it's fun
because they have fun powers in this
you're like oh no it's torture and their
lives are awful but it's cool okay for
my 15 seconds some of you saw me
tweeting about this and thought I had
lost my mind I did because there is a
trailer for a movie coming out called
wheelie and it's a Malaysian knockoff of
the Pixar Cars movie
it's a beat for beat pretty much stole
an idea for it
I believe that Pixar went through time
and stole the idea for wheelie and made
three movies out of it of course you can
make but as you know in our beloved
video here on new rock stars watch the
cars universe I did the same kind of
deep dive on my Twitter handle a da vas
on some fun things that you might have
missed in the wheelie trailer Aaron do
you have I don't think I can compete
with that I just wanna say thank you for
having me well my thing is that the
SModcast is coming back this is Sam in
my video podcast that we do together
where we answer your questions and we go
on Sewer many tangents but the patreon
goal has been set up on geek balm we
just need about 42 more people signing
up and the minimums $2 for that one so
get involved help bring that show back
we've already done a photo shoot we've
already filmed the first episode I just
want a press room play
I just wanna press one get yeah what
does it make live you just want to press
that sweet sweet button but you can help
me with that one patron convoy such big
bomb thank you okay well now comes the
time to our return to our trivia
question that we asked earlier Sam's
going to read the question again
so our question was what town does Nick
Fury reveal he was born in to Captain
Marvel Eric Wright he says ah this
sounds like a Pokemon row row row in
Roanoke Virginia that's how you say
Roanoke yeah dang yes American term was
a season of American Horror Story it's
and it's a town in Virginia but it's an
also an island off of the coast of North
Carolina where an entire colony went
miss
see it's one of those crazy like Roanoke
and all right Maude we've got not sure
if this is a city but Oregon well Sam
wrote the city of the south you say get
close Matt you're a region I'm at least
I am feeling I'm definitely regionally
closer than you Baton Rouge Louisiana oh
yeah yeah yeah and Sam what was the
correct thing oh well buckle up kids
three two little drumroll no one did it
all right so what town is Nick Fury born
in Huntsville Alabama all right so our
judges what do you think who is the
closest I said the region so I pretty
much got it I we can move on just
qualified dirt's qualified Oregon is
same on the other side of country what
about Earth I said a thousand ways
inquiry hmm they're close third
this that's on you your decision also I
forgot that the question was NEMA City
South Australia missus South everywhere
[Music]
so you're gonna read our good-byes here
in any month gonna have to draw from the
game shame so first mod what do you have
to do this is a get out of jail card
pick another gif of shame and the person
to your right has to do it gets to read
the end and do it which I have written
this is right this is exciting all you
can eat buffet go nom nom nom nom so you
have to pantomime Cookie Monster I mean
as you read our goodbyes I'll read the
goodbyes yeah Aaron you just nom nom nom
we're listening to us over a podcast
just follow us on Twitter at new rock
stars to see what the hell we're talking
about well as Aaron eats away take
center stage here
okay that fake foods not gonna eat
itself I featured it like what is Robin
Robin with good with no but the the food
that they didn't have for them oh thank
you for watching or listening to this
week's episode of new rockso's debrief
you got to keep good we want to thank
our host Maude Garrett at mon garrett
the Phil valina fimo wasn't able to make
it this week we have Sam Bachelorette
Sam basher and me Eric Ross a TA vos and
another special thanks to Erin couch
let's see whats your twitter at erin
couch on twitter reminder that this is
available both in audio and video form
videos at youtube.com slash new rock
stars and you can get the audio anywhere
you get your podcasts but if uses MLA
app we'd really appreciate it leave
comments underneath the podcasts it
supports this show directly comment us
tweet us support us Edna rock stars like
this video or podcast shared around
subscribed in rock stars for the deep
dives know all the stuff you love thank
you everyone have a great weekend
[Music]